Just not too misleading.
There's a mathematical theorem
called the hairy dog theorem.
Hairy dog theory. Yes. I mean, that's
just a jocular terminology, right?
But you think of something
which is topologically a sphere,
that means you see it,
you imagine a dog shape,
but you could sort of move it around with
a piece of plasticine until it looked
like a sphere. It doesn't
have holes in it. Okay.
Forget about his digestive system.
You see,
you're thinking about the surface
outside and then you're out.
The problem is you try to comb the hair
on the dog all the way around and the
theorem says there's got to be somewhere
with the hair doesn't lie flat and you
tried it on a sphere.
There's gotta be a point where with the
hair makes a kind of singular point.
So it's a bit like that. You have no idea
where the singularity is, but you know,
from general, top logical reasons
that there's got to be one somewhere.
And that was the tour of
argument that I produced. And uh,
I guess a lot of people,
it'd be trouble because they
never seen this kind of argument.
And a lot of people picked up on it
and particular Stephen Hawking and uh,
it became for a while, uh,
many people working on it,
I guess it's not so popular now because
probably will run out of theorems.
The idea of a singularity is
when you see something like a,
a Quasar or the,
the center of a galaxy.
Um, and we were talking a lot of black
hole. When you say a singularity, what,
what exactly are you, do
you mean by that? Well,
the normal expectation is that you have
a place like in the middle of the up and
Amazon,
that dust cloud,
that a point there where the
density becomes infinite.
And so the curvature of
space time becomes infinite.
So you have a place where the equations
and run away and they go to infinity and
you say, well, something's gone wrong.
But maybe initially it was in
these very symmetrical cases,
but what you could show by these indirect
arguments that somewhere somebody has
got to go wrong.
You can't continue the equations of
Einstein and they got stuck to the place
where they go in from it.
Or what in detail happens.
The theorems don't tell you.
They just say that something goes wrong
and that's what we call the singularity
and if a black hole is larger or smaller,
the singularity remains constant.
It remains in in there.
It's remains in there,
but it's not measurable in terms of its
actual size or whether you can measure
size very well cause it's size.
I said that's an intriguing question.
You might say the size is going to zero.
It could be quite
complicated in irregular,
not like the original Avenova
slide or one of my soldiers.
Even then the point is the wrong point
of view, but let's not go into that.
Now if there is something about
the structure of these things,
you can say they're not all the same.
No. Then the singularity is in Arlington,
but the black holes are not all the same.
They're not all the same, but the this,
one of the strange things about black
holes is that if you let them settle down,
they're not all the same to begin with,
but there are not many different
things they can settled into.
They can have rotation.
They can have a certain mass and the
mass translates into the size of the
diameter of the hole.
And you've also got a rotation so they
can rotate these sweatshirt found the non
wrote anyone's and it was Roy occur
in Australia and who first produced a
solution for a rotating
black hole rotating. Yes,
a rotating one.
But then you see the remarkable thing
is that's what they settled down too.
So there are good theorem this which
tell you that the general black hole to
very complicated,
fairly rapidly will settle down and
become one of these care solutions.
The rotating black hole.
I remember when I first saw
that documentary and I saw the,
when they were discussing the,
the shape of these galaxies and that
the center of it had this super massive
black hole that was slowly
devouring the galaxy. It's,
it is an unbelievably beautiful yet
simultaneously terrifying idea is that
there's this infinite power in the
center of infinite mass that's absorbing
slowly but surely everything around it.
But it's not an infinite mass.
The mass is quite well defined and
there's not an infinite, but yeah,
always a good question.
I mean if you wait forever,
how much of the mass actually gets
swallowed by the black hole? You see,
I think the, the pictures to think not
just the one galaxy, but the cluster.
UCR Galaxy has this 4 million solar mass
black hole and we are on a collision
course with the Andromeda galaxy
and I don't know how long,
but many book some time in the
future. Yes. The black holes,
we'll probably spiral into each
other and there'll be one big one.
So it's definable mass,
but in infinite density and
that this point, which were,
they were speculating that this could
possibly in the center of the supermassive
black holes, if you could go through that,
there would be another universe. Well,
speculations, a nice romantic
thought. It's more woo woo,
I'm afraid. So also good though. Yes,
I know it's a shame for science fiction
because it makes a nice thing that we
try to make things more complicated than
they are because they're so complicated
as it is dark matter for instance,
it,
it boggles the mind that we don't
really totally understand what 90 plus
percent. Well, that's a good question.
And what does that stuff, well,
do you want me to tell you
my theory? Yes, please.
Why do you see it's part of a story which,
um,
I don't know about 15 years ago,
I must have years of passing back.
I don't remember how long ago
now. So I had this idea, you see,
the universe as a whole is expanding now,
um,
early in the this century.
Don't ask me dates again.
Um, some people by observing
supernova saw exposing sauce very,
very far away.
They found out that the university is
actually accelerating and it's expansion.
And some people found this very
mysterious. On the other hand,
it's in all the cosmology books
because there is that expectation.
You see, in 1915 I signed,
produced his general theory.
In 1917 he introduced what's
called the cosmological constant.
So you think of a,
it was called lambda,
you think of a v shape turned upside down,
which is Amanda.
And he introduced this term for the
wrong reason because at that time people
weren't, there was some indication
in the universe was expanding,
but not very clear. An Einstein, uh,
I guess maybe didn't know I
didn't believe it. And this,
the couples observations hadn't yet
come to make a convincing case of the
expansion. So I sign, I thought,
well maybe the universe is static.
It's kind of philosophically nice to think
that it's sitting there all the time.
And he couldn't make it do that.
Uh,
so he had to introduce this term
called the cosmological constant.
And he did that.
And then not while very much longer
after this Hobo showed that the universe
does seem to be expanding.
And Einstein regarded this lambda
term as his biggest blunder,
which is an irony because it turns
out that this term is probably the
explanation for the expansion
of the universe that we now see.
So it's what people call dark energy.
I don't like the term very
much cause it's neither dark,
no proper energy in any clear sense.
But still that was not worry about that.
Right. It's a, it's a, it's
an odd term. Yes. I think so.
It's a little confusing cause
there's dark matter as well,
which is quite different.
You know, should,
it must be confused with the
dark energy as it's called,
of the cosmological constant,
which as far as we can tell,
it is completely consistent
with the observations.
It's a positive number,
very small,
but seems to be producing this expansion.
And I'm quite happy with that viewpoint
because it leads to a picture,
which I've been trying to plug for
a while now, maybe up to 15 years.
I can't remember. Um, the idea,
I know it's hard to explain,
but let me try.
It came about because I was worrying about
the remote future and I was thinking,
okay, when these black holes around this
fall in all the stars and they're just
sitting around, and what's the
most next exciting thing happening?
Well, the hawking evaporation,
they're going to radiate away.
Stephen Hawking showed that black holes
had this temperature is extremely cold.
I mean,
these enormous ones are absurdly cold,
much colder than anything
made on the earth. And uh,
but when the universe expands
and expands and expands,
it gets colder than the black holes.
And so those black holes get,
become the hottest, hottest things
around. And so they radiate away very,
very slowly. This hawking
radiation and that carries energy.
And so they shrink and shrink and the
shrink and finally they disappear with a
pop. I said pop is probably
a pretty big explosion, but,
but I'm not that big from a
cosmological astrophysical scale.
So the disappear,
well it maybe been pretty boring when
you're sitting around waiting for the
black hole and go pop. But
afterwards, that's really boring.
So this was a picture I thought off
and being rather depressed by it,
thinking that stats are that fate.
You see the feed of all the
interesting things happening.
Ultimate fate is this
unbelievably boring final state.
Okay, this is an emotional argument,
but giving me a bit of leeway.
So I began to think,
well,
it's not going to be us who are going to
be bored because we're not going to be
around the main things that we'll
be around. We'll be photons.
And it's pretty hard to Bora
photon for two very good reasons.
One is it probably doesn't have
conscious experiences. Not that sure. So,
but the other is more of the science
point that that they don't measure time
because the photon has no mass.
It travels at the speed of light
and what the way relativity works,
it means that clocks stopped if you like.
So if it had experiences with the moment
of its creation would be one moment and
the next moment would be infinity.
And so they're just zip out to
infinity without noticing thing.
Now she had been doing
work on this kind of thing,
thinking more about
gravitational radiation and
how you measure it's energy and
things like that.
And it was a very useful picture too.
Squashed down infinity.
A useful thing to think about here,
if you see these pictures by the
Dutch artist Mc Escher. Yeah.
And there are those which
are called circle limits,
and there's a very famous one with angels
and devils interlocking and they get
all crowded up onto
the edge and they want,
you've got to think about is that this
is a kind of geometry called hyperbolic
geometry,
and the angels and devils live in that
geometry and the ones right close to the
edge think they're the same size and
same shape as the ones in the middle. Oh,
you got it. Great. Yeah.
And so the idea is that if you look at
it from the angels and devils point of
view, that's infinity, that
boundary. But from our point of view,
we can look at,
and we have what's called a conformal map.
That picture is a conformal map,
but that means is that little
shapes are quite consistently drawn,
but there can be big or small and you
don't care about whether they're big or
they're small. Small shapes are
accurate or angles if you like,
her correctly drawn.
So it's what's called a conformal map.
And that can form a map,
describes infinity.
Now you can do the same thing to
the universe. When I say do it, um,
you can imagine it where
this remote future,
you can squash it down
just like in the ash,
a picture to a finite boundary.
And as far as the things with no mass,
they don't have a way of
measuring how big or small it is.
The Maxwell equations don't know
the scales, they don't care.
It's that work just as well for smaller,
so big and you can stretch it in
someplace and squash it somewhere else.
As long as the stretching
and squashing is isotropic.
So just as much one way as the other way,
which means more or less that you keep
what I call the light cones there.
And it's not going to details here,
but it means that if you have
things without mass and most
particularly the photons,
then that boundary is
just like anywhere else.
And the photons go zipping up to it.
And so you might think they've got to
have somewhere to go, okay, well that's,
you don't have to think that.
But that was the point of view I had.
The photons need to need
somewhere to enter it in a way.
But then where does it go?
But then there's the other picture,
which is the opposite.
Then there's the big bang.
Now you can do a similar
sort of trick there,
which is stretching it out and making
it into a boundary and that can be done
too. I played around with these ideas
for a long time and the standards,
cosmology and models you can do it with,
but the more complicated cosmology
models you might have one,
which a very complicated,
big bang.
The general ones don't
look like that at all,
so you need to condition which tells
you that the big bang was a very special
kind that it was.
It's all tied up with this thing called
the second law of thermodynamics and it
all ties together with physics in a way
which perhaps we don't have time to talk
about,
but it seemed to me a really good idea
to have the condition on the big bang
that you could continue it
in the same way I should say.
The idea of doing this was a
former student of mine, Paul Todd,
who was a colleague of mine and
he used this continuum conform.
What continuation is,
is a nice way of saying what the condition
is on the big bang to give you what
you want. But that's a huge
condition, but it nevertheless,
it's what starts our universe off in,
in a very special state,
which is what we live off in a way.
It's the second law of thermodynamics
and needs that to get going anyway.
I don't know if you want to
worry about that, but anyway,
the point was that it looks as though
it's a good condition on the big bang,
but it also should be
conformally. Uh, like a boundary,
which if you had no mass,
you wouldn't notice it. Okay.
You've got particles with mass
running around near the Big Bang,
but as you get closer and closer
and closer to the energy goes up,
the temperature goes.
Zuni, zooming up these,
zipping around at such a speed that the
energy of their motion is much bigger
than the equals MC squared mass.
Einstein's mass,
the energy in the mass
is a certain amount,
but when they get so hot,
you can forget about the mass.
So they like photons behave
like particles without mass,
and so they're just interested
in the conformal geometry.
So the crazy idea I had,
not just on the stretch out of the
big Vangie swatched on the infinity,
but maybe our big bang was a squash
down infinity of a previous Ian.
So I'm saying our Ian
began with a big bang,
ended up with this exponential expansion.
There was another one before us.
They will be another one Ostriss. There
was another one before that and so on.
So it's an infinite cycle of big bangs.
That's the picture and constant expansion
to the point where there's no more
energy and then somehow or another,
a big bang comes out of that. Yes,
that's right. Well, that's the
tricky part that people have trouble.
It's universally accepted that
the big bang was an event.
There's no a pretty well universally
theories that are attractive.
I would say nothing terribly popular.
There are certain ideas which say you
can continue into the before the Big Bang
Paul Steinhauser and what
are they thinking? It's it's,
it has things in common with my
model but it's not quite the same.
And you see it still is,
he there wasn't right not
long after Einstein produces
theory and this Alexandra
Friedman who was a Russian mathematical
physicist and he produced the first
cousin cause mammalogy mammals and one
of these was a one which has sort of
bounces and big bang.
It expands and contracts again
and it bounces and contract.
And so that was the one of his models.
The only trouble is if you put
irregularities into these models,
you get black holes and these black holes
could pull McCook and incredible mess
at the end. And that doesn't join onto
a nice smooth, big bang. The next one.
So you have trouble with those models,
but still people take these
things seriously. And as I
say, Steinhardt and tour,
I kind of a model which is like that.
So these are the things to think about.
My own view is that they don't take into
account the, the, the black hole problem,
which is that,
uh,
my one gets rid of that because the
black holes all evaporate away by hawking
evaporation. And uh, so it forms a model.
I used to give talks about
this feeling quite happy.
Nobody would ever prove it wrong
so I can go on and talking loud.
That's a no,
I wasn't quite happy with that.
And I thought maybe you could
see signals coming through.
So I had one idea about that, but more
recently, and this is only just this year,
um,
I have to polish colleagues.
That's a Christoph Meisner and Pav on
your rough ski and there is a Korean who
works in New York or Daniel an and we,
the four of us have a paper,
which I think today or tomorrow will be
the new improved version of this paper
should be on the archive. And
this, the title of the paper is,
are we seeing hawking
points in the CMB sky?
Now what's a hawking point?
He said it talks about the black holes.
See in the previous aeon two hours,
assuming it's more or less like ours,
they will be black holes in
clusters of galaxies. Huge,
enormous ones swallowing up pretty well.
The whole cluster.
And what happens to the energy
in those black holes? Well,
it goes out in hawking
radiation and it takes an age,
ages and ages and ages,
maybe 10 to a hundred year,
Google years or something,
ages and ages,
but all that energy in the picture
comes up basically one point.
Think of that as your picture and right
at the very edge you see that an awful
lot of angels and devils squashed together
there so that the entire radiation
from that single black hole will
be squashed into that little point.
And where on the other
side, what do we see? Well,
there will be a big release of energy at
that point and that's what we call the
hawking point and it spreads out.
You see what we see in the
cosmic microwave background.
This is radiation coming from all
directions and this radiation doesn't come
from the big bang.
Exactly.
It comes from 380,000
years after the big bang.
So there's a sort of last scattering
surface where the photons which are trying
to get out [inaudible] finally can escape.
And we see them now that spread out from
the hawking point to what you see and
the cosmic microwave background in the
last scattering surface is something of
the diameter of about eight
times the diameter of the moon.
No bigger,
no smaller.
Now you wouldn't see the whole thing
because our past cone, where were we?
What we see it cut across it.
We don't see the whole thing,
but we see probably most of it.
So you could urge,
imagine something from about four
to eight times the moon's diameter,
which is a small region
which is highly energetic,
more energetic in the middle and it
tapers off as you go to the edge.
And we seem to see these things,
the analysis that um,
that the polls,
they have the techniques and
the actual analyzing the data.
This is the Planck satellite data
who's done by Daniel [inaudible].
And then we look at the data and we seem
to see an effect which see what you do
is you, we've got only one universe.
That's what to complain about.
So how do you know if
something's real or not?
What you make zillions of fake universes
and you compare this with them and
there's a lot of technique
about how you do this. But um,
Daniel first did a thousand of these
fakes and they were sort of two sizes of
these.
You look at these rings to see whether
the temperature goes out from the outside
to the middle.
And there were two sizes,
both within the size of I'd say
about four degrees across the sky.
And um, there was no evidence
of him at all in the simulation.
So this is a real effect.
Okay.
Then people were skeptical of
this for one reason or another.
So Daniel did another,
well 10,000 altogether and you cage
Nunnelly they or to which do what,
two or three to be precise where you
see this effect in the simulations.
But if you work out the probability
that this is a real effect,
you come up with a confidence level
of 99.98% that this is a real effect.
So we're waiting to see
what people say about this.